hey everyone a plan the quest the end
now that's your boy psycho Wow well
let's do this I kanya right here one
Kanye press the paw hmm here the
government walk 369 248 initial tests of
the override system more heavily
protected systems or still we stop tests
before it better MMA last Etta
good luck sir good luck
ok
hey
good luck hey Fox
so I set
that was i okay route for the candy rat
catch I'm run and benches I'm Ron and
let just I'm running at the end of the
struggle only one courier remained in
the heart of the divide the true courier
about courier 6 the courier toward the
ancient flag of the Commonwealth from
its cables and cast it over the corpse
though whether done as a sign of respect
or an anger for what had been endured to
reach this moment that is unknown
interpretation is something best left to
history and only the surviving courier
would ever know for certain okay as for
the courier he turned his back on his
home for the second time and made his
way back navigating the treachery of the
divide tunnelers and the marked men
avoided the lone figure as if
recognizing the courier's right to
passage or out of fear the courier
walked until he stood again upon the
edge of the divide the last road he
would walk before the second battle for
Hoover Dam
there beside his feet was a final
package from one courier to another a
footlocker bearing a gift and a message
lip but that message it is something for
couriers to carry and for them alone let
up the lights flickered across the
divide let let reminders that the old
world histories persist yeah and find
meaning in the present again it said war
war never changes
Oh